hello there reject nation we're gonna
watch the witcher episode four of season
two
guys if you end up enjoying our reaction
why don't you go ahead and hit that like
button also subscribe and click that
notification bell to get notified
whenever our reaction for the next one
is up full length watch as long as
you're single with the time code or over
at our patreon page or wherever we cover
many shows with the same tier you get
the optional reaction highlights and
watch alongs included lastly thank you
to the boys at prepper for helping us
edit down these highlights
must be nothing
what are we doing
hesitation will draw danger to you like
fire
but trust the path you choose
and it will protect you
even in darkness
as long as you listen i noticed they
never have a cold breath do they film
this in real snow
[Music]
god damn sir i'm getting messed up put
some snow on it
i'm not going to hurt you
wha
i'm going to care more
is that where you're headed
interesting let me look
girl's just gonna behead her what did i
tell you about talking to strangers
you're a sorceress
like jennifer
dress
and a friend of girls he must be quite
charitable
oh he can learn that jennifer's alive
yeah
his search was not in vain
[Applause]
[Music]
good elf is a dead alpha he even got
graffiti in these times stop fidgeting
why are they so freaking mean to elves
man i can't wait
could i be escorted to an alley yeah
well who can't why you can't like can it
thank you sir
what then oh
believe yourself
oh
yes
dick prison didn't exactly do you any
favors i have a mission to complete we
must get back to cintra
sure the north guardians will be
thrilled to have me
those robes draw a lot of attention
proclaimed as intria
and frangilla's leadership friendship
it's funny how quickly people forget
about you when you're no longer of use
to them isn't it
[Music]
no
[Music]
of course now she's the elven mage
great oh man i gotta get out of here
with no magic
i kind of look like the people in those
photos though i will not live in fear
nor would we ask you to we only want to
serve redania as best we can
drink it
this happens every day center is the
point your highness we would never have
taken it from kalanthi
but now
central could be ours if we're smart
ah great
that's exactly where jennifer's head
like that
looks like a wraith and it looks like
that dagger that they got in karemorin
like a dress
give it to me
i like everything about you
i brought it here for you
to help guide you
to be your mom
come
let this hate crime happen thought you
could get away
i had that covered of course you did
i would start running shouldn't like get
his armor and wear it right that did not
drop more attention
oh yeah
literal [ __ ]
we're safer down here than we are up
there
oh oh god the sandpiper
helped elves get to zentria if you know
our way to sintra and help us i can
assure you your pick of land on our safe
return i hope you're a man of your word
all right come on
it appears you have some use after all
thankfully men remain simple
yeah
no questions asked what helped you
oh no
let's go
3po
i've never seen anything like it
but it did try to get her
both of them did
to do what
i didn't let her live long enough to
find out she's asking some questions
if a mage has been involved
that component will glow
i'll know by morning
in the meantime i'm sorry about eska
i'm sorry about sultan
tell him about yet of her
those who died i
i say their names at night when i lay
down so i don't forget
she's not gonna say yeah
i'm so rapey god we gotta go 13
stay with me
tonight i'm sorry
you're ugly to me
[Laughter]
friend zoned by a witcher i know
oh my god that close to finding out
about jennifer humans built their world
on top of our ruins
[Applause]
dude humans suck we don't have the fight
left anymore to start anew the north
have made sure of that
[Music]
i'll borrow your help then a man needs a
oh good guy i knew it he was in the
water damn it
no dude oh they better save him
[Applause]
now's your chance to prove yourself
no
we have to wait for the place to empty
then the piper will take us to the boat
the sandpiper that's the one he performs
here every night
come on please
yes
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
huh it doesn't seem to take in the
applause as much anymore getting an elf
into cintra won't be a problem
it needs to be the right one
so more malleable
distrustful
in all the right ways
you
no
what
no what
is that a flower in your hair girl
you never got my rags that clean yeah
like you ever wash oh
she's excited
come on you say you're mutants
that's why you don't understand what
people feel but the truth is
you're choosing to be ignorant [ __ ]
aren't you
lay it down damn
everyone has to write a letter to siri
now
i'm sorry
my grandmother fought battles animal
dresses
you can do both
yeah girl
stop reinforcing old gender stereotypes
geralt
now there is something strange
uh
how did two different monsters wind up
with the same dust on them they came
from the same place
a monolith
what are you not saying mana what now
i saw a monolith topple
how
oh
daughter of chaos belongs to us turn
your backs
join the procession
when the black knight captured me
i was scared
i screamed
and that's when the monolith cracked and
fell
and if these monsters are my fault it's
all right how would that have given
birth to these monsters
no idea
unless just having the debris from it
out in the atmosphere
and if they ingest it or something or it
gets on them
um
bad
what are you doing here
and
what fresh
hell did you just crawl out of sewer
what's your excuse oh sewer i always
knew you were a blood-sucking joyless
[Laughter]
the sandpiper
what no yes no
why did you say that name i would not
wish that fate on my worst enemy and yes
you are
firmly lodged in that category it has to
be said
and sooner or later they will come
forever
anyone that they deem
the other
we leave oxford at nightfall
plenty of time to take a bath before
then
just saying
i wouldn't care how universe smells
you are important to me dress
you always will be
there's the big softy
validating people left and right
i have a friend who studies monoliths
i can portal you to him
there you go
no
[ __ ]
oh my god
where the [ __ ] are you
it's the third scene where they ask him
a question
cuts away
yeah i'm gonna find out a lot off screen
third seen this episode
papers for the trousers please papers
absolutely papers
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks for the tunes my niece just loves
her oh that's lovely well bless her
bless yourself if you don't mind me
saying so that one it's uh
it's not your strongest oh god
oh yeah
it's a bit complicated it took me to the
fourth verse to understand no different
time
[Music]
the bit when the loop player ends up
with the warrior ladies lovable lovable
luterness yeah
didn't really ring true for me i must
say
is what we're watching his
with this whole you know if you could
write yourself a little song you could
sing yourself whatever you please but
you can't
no
dark side escape grace a crawling what
have you done jasper oh
yeah
i'll distract him you take them onto the
boat like hell
oh
homeboy's already got you this ship's
not going anywhere till i check your
papers
shout it [ __ ]
the no
no dude you're
going to die
[ __ ] the elves
oh damn that was
not a heroic sacrifice feeling that
sucks
poor guy
oh something not right with those bones
is that work
she blood i think it might be yeah tell
me what i'm looking at here
feinwood
this only grows while the blood has been
spilled
there are legends
that elder blood was one of the key
ingredients in the creation of the first
witcher mutagens
not another witcher has been created
since destiny has given us a gift
oh siri siri
we need to harvest our blood asap we
all of us would be dead without you no
i'm dora wow
jennifer if you harm one hair on
yaskir's head
hi oh what the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
damn it
i didn't realize we were close to ending
the episode
how hard is it for tris to say one thing
just one sentence
jennifer is alive
instead of wait for me to get through
all 12 13 of these names so that i can
reveal to you that what's the one i'm
not gonna say
she must know that in some way they had
something right was there something
there i don't know i don't think she
made it she might not know
she probably held out because she was
trying to get in geralt's bed that's
right like cockroach rat infested
witcher bed of his yeah that's how you
know it's a warm one
ah man that's too bad i feel sorry for
her man i did too have all those burn
marks all over her to feel scarred like
that but i think the
the connection and the vulnerability
that they've been drawing for geralt has
been really strong for this show it's
been just enough they haven't been
overdoing it where it feels like we've
done a big character rewrite on the guy
like you see him naturally becoming more
expressive and more open with the way he
thinks and feels about things but still
choosing the right moments to be
completely reserved
uh i think that's really strong stuff
and
yeah what they've been doing with siri
of just uh
amping because it's like we haven't
really known what her
ultimate destiny plan is and we still
don't quite know what it is but there's
been so much emphasis on destiny with
regards to her plot line and now we're
getting a better sense of what that
might all entail
and you know like her creation of
destroying that monolith that was the
first episode right right then when she
was running away from the black knight
the guy here who's with
jennifer that was the first episode and
then when the ground split
yeah she like she screams out and leaves
that like scorch mark yeah yeah uh i
think that's what they're referring to
in destroying the monolith
and how that gave birth to
but why would that
would the monster seem to be like so
close to where they are
well
yeah and it seems at least as he
describes it it seems like they're
targeting her specifically like she was
drawn to them they were drawn to her so
at least right now it seems as though
whatever you know moment that was where
she broke the monolith and
you know whatever that effect had
somehow you know links in the telepathic
way or something yeah i mean there's a
lot that still i think needs to be
explained but maybe it's the others
particulate from and out into the world
and you never know what effect that'll
have and it could create more witchers
apparently yeah that's cool her her
blood is so significant it's gotta bleed
her out man it's gonna bleed her out as
much as possible mm-hmm just like put
her in a room just like get her on a
machine just always be extracting blood
i mean they don't need much blood like
the tiny bits of blood that shed on the
ground seem to produce life mm-hmm
so that's cool yeah
that's a neat neat path here i think
every like even characters like trista
who i didn't really care for in the last
season i like a lot more here
um this this path that had on me
they're going to sintra too right
because yeah they have to go to
centuries to the monolith we are on the
same linear timeline
i like how we got all meta
that's the theme in the last few years
isn't it oh everything has to be
meta
and uh
i met her with uh jasper's um
song when he was encountering that guard
and just makes you go is every story
we're watching just told from his point
like this is his
perspective in some way yeah the whole
show is doing the show the whole show is
reminded we're gonna
cut away the final episode he's just
like telling a story and you realize
this is all you ask your story the
entire time we've been watching it
through his narration of the continent
yes
or he made it all up
it's interesting because this this
season i've been getting two towers
meets pirates of the caribbean at
world's end vibes
yeah yeah good one yeah yeah
it's been the the kind of the tonal
links that i've been seeing here and i
think it's really neat what they've been
doing jennifer too of stripping her from
her magic and bringing her back to just
being a human
um just the life experiences they throw
that actress way whose name i still
don't know but the experiences they
throw her away are so
strong they give her so much context to
work with and i am starting to warm up
to the
the former baddie oh yes yes uh uh kahir
mm-hmm i think his name is yeah i don't
know if i could trust him yet he makes a
lot of promises and i'm like let's see
if you follow through with all that [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah but yeah once we get it
we'll see but for right now i am
enjoying their uneasy alliance and i
thought that scene in the sewers
was a nice sort of
i mean you know it's it's there
obviously partly to set up that guy's
sacrifice later on because he feels
guilty but i like that you
especially in a moment like that can
peer around at me like okay what is
everyone's motivation what side is
everybody on jennifer's trying to do the
right thing here clearly wants to follow
the other guy but then he at least
sticks around to save her so yeah it's
just like an interesting
uh little toppling of the motivational
dominoes it's like this guy doesn't mean
much to us and she's just trying to save
him just because true yeah and you know
jennifer is valuable to him in some way
and so yeah just like watching their
inner play through things like that and
watching as they potentially start to
grow a bond i think is is a nice
dramatic device a because it gives
yennefer a you know
someone
a vanilla somewhat of an ally to open up
to before we get to yaskir or to at
least form some kind of bond with
uh and then you know we can also
sort of uh what am i trying to say it
gives her
yeah that that means of opening up
uh but also you know a piece of steaks
now as something to kind of wonder about
as we head into the night episode yeah
i sure i like the way they're bonded
formed a lot and watching the how
the last time we were gas here and
seeing
just how heartbroken he was over those
events and
to see a guy who thrived off of the
tension yeah and
you know it was very narcissistic but
you could tell there was heart
underneath and now it's kind of flipped
where he's become a lot more bitter and
cynical
towards life and he doesn't really care
for the
the luxury of fame
as much like even when he was finishing
his song you could see him reliving the
pain
and being thrown off by the applause
like getting lost in the memory it's
like the sheen of it all is just this
something that he can see past now and
doesn't buy into any of it
so much to the point where he messes up
the plant and gets so provoked yeah
he can can't deal with youtube comments
apparently
yeah yeah yeah
dude you should be lucky enough that
people are gathering around to hear him
these days it might be worth it he
didn't he couldn't accept the criticisms
of which were season one
that that's essentially what happened
yep this is the this is the for the
writers speaking through the voice of
yasuki
yeah they all found themselves reflected
don't think we didn't hear you oh they
know they know i like the timeline stuff
i thought that made part of the fun of
the show yeah yeah well and i i think we
had an easier time with it
yeah given that a people were like okay
you gotta know there's some timeline
stuff but also just watching all of
these in such a tight succession too
very true but yeah um watch watching
their bond and how that shifted of how
they're two very different people has
led to a place where they can understand
each other now
and
um
yeah this whole thing with uh the elves
like they've just been
they really explored that
to a certain extent in the first season
you get more knowledgeable they
elaborate upon it more within um
uh uh nightmare of the wolf
and then here
they really feel like they're few
undertalks and it sucks because they are
the they're the this all stems from them
like the magic and everything and then
now to watch just how poorly treated
they are
it's this like segregation
almost makes you think of like america
and native americans you know yeah or
anybody anybody deem and they even say
it like overtly in the text anybody who
becomes the other
you know mainstream society
it's such a
harrowing situation for them to be
thrusted into yeah i wish we'd learned
what that creature was in the sewers
i felt like that was the thing they like
planted there and then
kraken jr felt like didn't get much of a
payoff to it i mean yeah the person died
and then it's set up for that person to
come back later to sacrifice which i'm
glad they got a little bit of a
redemption moment in there
and it's also a moment where you're like
creature but there's no geralt so like
you know this might be hairier than
normal but yeah at the same time it'd be
like what is that yeah it's it's funny
it's like yeah i wish we could see more
or no more but at the same time i do
appreciate that it makes the world feel
that much more like oh there aren't just
creatures like in the woods or in a cave
somewhere like you might run a fowl of
one that's true you know in a civilized
populated area too
so then it just yeah it fills out the
world a little bit
but it does also seem like a pretty
significant creature
like you know kraken octopus thing
that just lurks about this city yeah
like lives in the sewer and waits for
people yeah like how many people are
coming through here that you get to eat
how have you you lived all this time i
wonder if they are banished you know
when the witches are turned into eels or
something
or if it's something like that yeah yeah
yeah they lurk in there in the sewers
now yeah
to to fuel somebody else's magical
whatnot
maybe
yeah because uh i didn't really
understand the
the emotional
or how that really drove the narrative
forward
i know it seems like i'm loading in on a
really small thing
since i'm like do we really need that
deaf guy to die
to have that scene where that dude does
sacrifice like how much of that do we
really need
um like i feel like there still could
have been someone who does but i guess
you needed someone to propel themselves
forward for the sacrifice
yeah and i i think it also just
controlled this temper a little bit
well there's that and i and i guess it's
also like you know i i took it partly as
to playing off that moment at the very
end when jennifer's like well
now i've got to go back for you i think
i think it all that scene boils down to
the line of he would have done the same
thing and you're like i don't know if he
would man and then also now we gotta
watch as everybody else has to kind of
reckon with am i the one who's gonna
leave somebody and just run off and save
my own skin
and it's like you know here is the one
in that ending scene was like nerves we
don't have time for this come on i mean
i think jennifer would because
especially because like yaskir got them
on the boat yeah i think she would go
back yeah yeah but it's that debate of
like she has every reason not to
theoretically because he's just risked a
whole bunch to get her in there in the
first place yeah and now she's gonna
have to go out and make the risk to get
him
safe
but but yeah i mean you make good points
yeah so it i think it thematically
bounces off of the other stuff i mean i
disagree with you i i'm not open-minded
to hearing a perspective to make me
understand something that's a good
discussion
that gets more comments and clicks right
yeah let's get everybody else mad at the
comments too
[Laughter]
engagement maybe the target engagement
yeah
yeah
come at me uh yeah
yeah man and then and uh siri is an
elder
it's funny how this was the there's a
fourth episode right
and then they they acknowledge the
events of the fourth episode that was
like when they brought it back like i
didn't know about the timeline so the
fourth episode yeah i guess so this even
works on that meta english
yeah it's a nice mirror
and two i mean well done in the build up
it's like
i've been missing askier but when he
shows up i wasn't really thinking about
it so it makes it that much more
rewarding like oh yes he's back yeah
time has passed he's a little bit
different now
uh but yeah the solid stuff yeah
there's a bleak realism to this magical
world i'm running out yeah which part
why i think of like two towers and
the third pirates movie oh yeah there's
that whole thing where the that roided
out guy like stops his the the
confusingly named visimir
from being poisoned and then he's like
talking back and forth with the owl and
like that's one of those scenes that's
very mystical because he seems to know
that this al has
a ability to perceive him and carry
messages or whatever but it's just yeah
it's just this guy talking to himself
essentially about all this craziness
around him they're really good at that
throughout this is like especially i
think we've commented like the second
season seems to have even more
just fantasy and magic apparent around
the margins or at least kind of used
in each episode to some extent but
they're really good at making it feel
like it's a tangible part of this world
yeah yeah i would agree with that
all right guys well there's only eight
episodes eight episodes almost done
halfway almost done mm-hmm
what did you think about the witcher
season two episode four leave your
thoughts down below only four more to go
then the journey's done forever no more
witchers no more witches for another
three or four years i hear there's a
spin-off in the works oh good then a
prequel and a cartoon
works for everybody doing that
it's always going to be good it's not
going to be this worked out well let's
let's spin off the [ __ ] out of this love
this let's dilute it make up some [ __ ]
and have another show but to be fair the
witcher world has always been very rich
that's true there were many a book
series
and a video game before that's true yeah
we'll see how the it was the origin of
the
show well but i'm sitting here going
we'll see how this game of thrones
prequel [ __ ] goes because i don't have
the biggest great expectations for that
but you know
oh yeah i forgot about that and there's
already been one game of thrones prequel
that's been cancelled before it even
aired and then there i don't know i hope
i'm rooting for the witcher stuff to be
great because i think the witcher itself
is great
all right guys leave your thoughts down
below hey hit that like button i'll
catch you guys soon
you